Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P,
you can call absolutely anytime you want.
Yesterday on the show, I sort of offhandedly made
an analogy when it comes to asymmetric risk and
a mathematical term called expected value. And I
talked about a ten sided die and I incorrectly
said the expected value would be five. I got a
number of polite voicemails and emails saying,
David, you got that wrong. Here is one of them.
Speaker 6: David, sir, I believe you made a
mistake in your discussion of expected value
on the show. Yes. If you were a 10 sided die and
earn the amount of money that shows up on the day,
such as $1 for a one, dollar for
two, et cetera, as you discussed,
your expected value is actually five dollars and
fifty cents, not just five dollars. Yes. Just try
to add up all the numbers from one to 10 and
divide by 10. It's five fifty. You need a nine
tie to die for the expected value to be $5, which
I'm not sure is geometrically possible. Anyways, I
appreciate your attempt to incorporate statistics
into the show and keep up the good work.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I received many corrections.
The expected value of the imaginary 10 sided die
is five fifty, not five. The point
I was trying to make still remains,
but I appreciate being corrected and I appreciate
the audience for keeping me honest but also
accurate. And it is an expected value of 550 if
you don't even know what I'm talking about. Not
a big deal. We have a. Bonus show for you today.
The Amod Arbery killing with three defendants in
that trial has moved beyond closing arguments and
is as we speak in prosecution, rebuttal. And we're
going to talk about how this case differs from
the Kyle Rittenhouse case on today's bonus show.
We're also going to talk about this bizarre
incident where a truck carrying cash had some
kind of an issue where the cash ended up scattered
all over a California freeway and it caused quite
a frenzy. We'll also talk about the difference
between a freeway and a highway. I still don't
understand it. Maybe there isn't one. We will
also talk about the COVID spike that's going on
in some parts of the United States. Things are
as bad right now as they were last November.
Why? And what is the outlook? We're going to
talk about all of it on today's bonus show. You
can sign up on my website. Join Packman dot com.
Become a member. Get instant access to the bonus
show. We will be here tomorrow with a new show and
then off the rest of the week for Thanksgiving.
But many programs still coming up between
Unidentified: now and the.